it began like any other dunk contest
two of the league's best dunkers aaron
gordon and derek jones jr
facing off in a battle of wills that
would ultimately be decided by a fair
and impartial panel of judges
judges who are honest and just
but that's not what happened when it
comes to the most unforgettable moment
of the night
it wasn't a dunk from either contestant
it wasn't even a dunk
it was dwayne wade leveling a lukewarm
nine
and to those who know him best it was
the latest clue in a lifelong mystery
that may never be solved
[Music]
you know i'm not surprised i've known
dwayne since he was a little boy
he was never easily impressed
our investigation delved deep into
wade's childhood
where we found a shocking pattern of
unimpressed reactions
to objectively excellent things
this lack of appreciation continued
through his formative years
he found no joy even in life's most
beautiful music
listen i love d wade like a brother
but he's always been like this one time
i saw him drink a sprite from mcdonald's
and he didn't even react
have you ever had a fountain sprite for
mcdonald's that
hits we hired the nation's top private
investigators to find a possible motive
into our dismay nothing was found
until this if you look at wade's hands
you see one two
three four five six
seven eight nine fingers
wayne wade even gives one of the most
iconic moments
a moment that he himself was a part of a
nine
there were more questions than answers
how and why
could a legendary three-time nba
champion behave like this
i said i didn't want to talk about it
leave me alone
on the next episode blake griffin
responds to the critics who say he
didn't really jump over the kia
what do you have to say to them